this video is brought to you by
expressvpn and Shopify people more on
them after the
reaction citizens of the reject Nation
just in time for Christmas it is time to
celebrate some Christ unmasks this is
Monty Python's Life of Brian and we
haven't seen it ever no none of them n
not of one this is the first of the
Monty pythons yeah we doing it uh that
said we've never seen any Monty Python
so uh mon python could be a journey we
go on together if this goes well so
please do like please do comment let us
know below what your favorite Monty
Python movie is let us know what your
favorite I don't know Psalm what section
of the Bible is your favorite or chapter
I call them Clips or clip from the Bible
do you enjoy uh literally have no idea
what this movie about very excited to
dive into it want to thank our friends
at prepper for assembling this video and
making it possible want to thank our
folks over at the patreon for being the
sexiest rejects in the game even SE J
little diaper they're that sexy you
wanted to if you'd like to become a
patron you can watch this beginning end
front to back the whole journey
including our resting watching faces
yeah they're good we're just pensive
we're good at it without further Ado I'm
about to find out so wait I didn't get
to do my and everybody loves it ring the
bell ring the bell had to add it in I
know you guys would have left comments
being real Angry if you hadn't heard it
and now the seo's positive continue
because now they're acknowledging the
Bell which is nice and I just want your
likes because I need them for validation
but without further Ado we're gonna find
out what this Brian guy's up to in three
1 what a perfectly timed movie sounds
all christmy oh
[Music]
yes you think that's supposed to be
Jesus I think he's flying through the
air like Santa right is that what
Santa's based off of we can't see the
stars in Los Angeles that's way more
than I'm used to right there Silver
Surfer
confirmed or is it just the North Star
the three wise men will tell us that's
why they're wise
yeah it's Monty the Monty the dog see
patrons now those are some Regal sheep
is that a sheep they riding sheep can't
tell
no that's a camel right but it's like
got weird uh Fufu yeah it's like a sheep
camel it's like a
shamble oh look at the cute donkey
Dominic the Christmas donkey right yeah
is that part of the that's part of the
thing yeah ears
[Music]
ner wo
who are you we are three wise men what
well what are you doing creeping around
a car [__] at 2:00 in the morning that
doesn't sound very wise to me we wish to
praise the infant you're all drunk it's
disgusting OU we were led by a
star we must see him we have brought
presents gold frankincense M well why
didn't you say he's over there so you're
astrologers are you well what is he then
H what star sign is
he
astrologers Capricorn he is the Son of
God our Messiah King of the Jews that's
Capricorn is
it by what name are you calling him
Brian We Worship You O Brian Lord over
us
all praise unto you Brian and to the
Lord Our Father if you're dropping by
again do pop in and thanks a lot for the
golden frankincense but don't worry too
much about the myr next time I hope his
voice is like that all the time and
think it's not a bit it's just a in real
life like I'll be an actor yeah look
that oh is there a Manger next
door so a baby born the exact same time
that's the I's see he's neighborly Brian
poor Brian born moments too soon Oro
late oh my God this reminds me of like
remember in elementary school and they
used to teach you on like what is that
thing called the educational thing about
like uh spelling and rhyming and the
title sequence was just like this you
guys like they rhyme songs and they'd be
like will teach you about syllables guys
I know what you're talking about and
it's just escaping me and the chat right
now is like obviously the the
legislation like there's I'm a bill yes
something Rock Schoolhouse Rock yeah
yeah yeah
oh this is
[Music]
beautiful this song is epic a huge
opening credits but moving quick and
Lively Assistant Art directors were
usually bored by this point but not
today this is excellent there's a lot
happening this is like pretty good for
the 70s right 1979 this is very pretty
like this is like it's a whole thing I
don't know how you do this actually
yeah I love Terry gilliam's weirdness I
forgot he was part of the Monty Python
crew
[Music]
somehow so everybody's Jesus is 33 right
that's what ad BC how blessed are the
sorrowful they shall find consolation
how blessed are those who hunger they
shall see
God speak
up oh come on Brian will you be
quiet don't pick your nose picking my
nose I was scratching you was picking it
while he was talking to that
lady I was only asking her to shut up so
he can hear what he's saying big noos
don't you call my husband big noos could
you be quiet please what was that I
think it was blessed are the cheese
makers might be a bit about blessed are
the big noes oh lay off him where are
you two from no City one more time mate
I'll take you the cleaner
language or really we'll slug you s oh
it's the meek blessed are the meek oh
that's nice in it I'm glad they getting
something cuz they have elev a
time your no is going to be 3ot wide
across your face by time I finish for
you oh it yours angle last big brother
oh right that's your last warning oh do
pip
dance oh come on let's go to the
stoning oh is he in love immediately
yeah well what Jesus blatantly fails to
appreciate is it's the meek who the
problem yes de C abolutely R yes I see
Brian follow her Brian oh I ain't
wearing these beards why aren't women
allowed to go to stonings Mom it's
written that's
why feared Madam oh Luke I haven't got
time to go to no stonings he's not well
again my God yeah all right two points
Two Flats and a packet of gravel P get a
gravel gravel enjoy
yourselves
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
God Son of Deuteronomy of G do I say yes
yes yes do I say yes Guilty by the
Elders of the town of uttering the name
of our Lord he's a really nice curl in
his beard it's impressive a bunch of
them and all I said to my wife was that
piece of halib but was good enough for
Jehovah really
are there any women here
today by virtue of the authority rested
in me lay we haven't started
yet who threw that Stone come
[Music]
on I don't think it ought to be blessed
for me just saying Jehovah Jehovah
Jehovah Jehovah say Jehovah once more
right who do that is he like super tall
or are they all TI he looks very tall
was it you yes right well you did say
you
over no one is to Stone anyone until I
blow this whistle even and I want to
make this absolutely clear even if they
do say
[Music]
[Applause]
Jehovah good
job a talent for all X leop Bzz fa a
talent for all X leer a talent that's
more than he earns in a month off a
talent then now get away come on big
nose let's
haggle all right so my final offer check
for slipper 16 years behind a bell I'm
proud of yourself what happened I cured
sir yes some bloody Miracle sir God
bless you who cured you Jesus did Sir I
was hopping along B my own business all
of a sudden up comes ches me one minute
I'm a leop with a tra next minute my
livelihoods gone not so much as a are
your
Le why don't you go and tell him that
you want to be a leper again what was
think I was going to ask him if you'd
make me a bit lame in one leg during the
middle of the week you know something
beable but not leprosy which is a pain
in the
ass thank you sir
thankar me bloody life story there no
pleasing some people that's just what
Jesus said
sir that's me at every party I go to I
just like hop around wearing a fun
little diaper thing just bouncing like
why I've never seen that hot before and
I'm like don't iy know it what's he
doing here if it wasn't for him we
wouldn't have all this I know you are
asking me about your uh my nose your
father isn't Mr Cohen I never thought he
was no none of your
cheek he was a Roman Brian he was a
centurion in the Roman army cool you
mean you were at first yes who was it
nus maximus's name oh boy naus
[Music]
Maximus why don't they put long horns
like that anymore I'd like to know bring
them back contest
in I've been to the Calum less limbs now
but very pretty it is the birthright of
every man or woman why you always on
about women's stand I want to be one I
want you all to call me Loretta I want
to have babies it's every man's right to
have babies if he wants
them you can't have babies don't you
oppress
me I'm got a wound where's the feet
that's going to just take you're going
to keep it in a
box that he can have the right to have
babies which will fight the oppressors
for your right to have babies brother
sister what's the point of fighting for
his right to have babies when he can't
have babies it is symbolic of our
struggle against
[Applause]
oppression I'll just noticed I don't
want that Roman rubbish why don't you
sell proper food well don't blame me I
didn't ask to sell this stuff are you
the Judean People's Front off what
for the people's front of Judea can I
join your group no I didn't want to sell
this stuff it's only a job I hate the
Romans as much as
anybody oh yeah how much a lot right
you're
in we at more than the Romans the Judean
people Jud popular people
FR and the people's front of
judia people's front of Judea Splitters
where are the people's front of Judea
the redder whatever happened to the
popular
front he's over
[Laughter]
there I think I'm about to have a oh
[Applause]
boy
what's your name Bri Cen you may have a
little job for you Bri I wonder how many
like there were different groups and
members of different like you know
anti-establishment like I'm sure that
was based on something right like those
jokes like I'm sure there's humor were
just not understanding we're not cuz we
weren't born yet you guys not yet a
little early little
[Music]
early red R oh Roman I can read he's not
writing well right now
no uhoh uhoh the Romans are coming early
graffiti was even more dangerous people
call Roman they go the house it says
Romans go home what's L for Roman come
on come on Romanus goes like anus F PL
of anus is Annie
[Music]
ROM huh what is a go conjugate the ver
to
go third person plural present
indicative there you go but Romans go
home is in order so you must use the
imperative which
is how many
r e e go home this is motion to Wars
isn't it
boy except the Thomas takes
the
Latin Lon this is very funny that's
clever now right out under
times C it's not done by Sunrise I'll
cut your off oh thank you sir thank you
sir hell C and everything sir and
everything I never had to write a 100
times of anything because I was in
trouble that was not an ' 80s or '90s
thing I don't think that happened to me
no right
now don't do it
[Laughter]
[Music]
again run Brian run get out of there
Brian I like this
music
it's going to be
Judith oh oh hey girl hey Pilot's wife's
bedroom is here we inform pilot that
she's in our custody and forth with this
you areand they T everything we had and
not just from us from our fathers and
from our father's fathers and from our
father's father's fathers yeah and from
our father's father's father's
father and what have they ever given Us
in return the
aqueduct that's true and there
sanitation and the roads but apart from
the sanitation the aqueduct and the
Roads Irrigation
medicine
education this is that like how often
you think of the Roman Empire thing as a
skit yeah mon python thought of the
Roman Empire part from the sanitation
the medicine education wine public order
irrigation row a freshwater system of
public health what have the Romans ever
done for us brought
[Music]
peace that's a fun little bit of
business with the The Legend of Romans
poor man my sight is poor my legs are
red and B all right
M it's all
clear
did he finish the slogan a 100 times in
letters 10t he before you join us know
this there is not one of us here who
would not gladly suffer death to rid
this country of the Romans once and for
all uh well
one from now on you shall be called
Brian that is called Brian there's a lot
of Mel Brooks like he clearly influence
Mel Brooks yeah this style of humor like
I grew up in Mel Brooks and this is a
lot of that flavor they the same vibe
make our way to the Northwestern main
drain we are sewage workers on our way
to a conference Ridge our glorious
leader and founder of the pfj will be
coordinating consultant at the drain
head though he himself will not be
taking part in any terrorist action as
he has a bad
back we enter the Caesar Augustus
Memorial sewer and from there proceed
directly to the hyper coost this has
just been retied so terrorists careful
with those
weapons
[Music]
perfect I it's a it's a comedy obviously
but I wonder about how they built all
these sets I know I was just thinking
about like that looked really cool in
the artwork on the ground and they must
have had to actually build that cuz they
don't have the technology to make that
later like that was a built set right
and like this underground stuff is
really cool yeah wonder if they filmed
in the actual like
Aqueduct campaign for free gallery think
was front of UD what's your group doing
here we're going to kidnap Pilot's Wife
take her back is your demand so we what
that's our plan we've been planning this
for months what tough titty for you fish
face Brothers Brothers we should be
struggling
together we should be United against the
common enemy The People's trunks no no
the
[Music]
Romans that was pretty
[Applause]
good
get out of there
[Music]
Brian maybe he'll get to meet his
dad you
lucky who's that you lucky lucky
bastard I've been here 5 years they y me
the right way up yesterday what will
they do to me oh you'll probably get
away with crucifixion crucifixion yeah
first offense
first offense best thing the Romans ever
did for us what oh yeah if we didn't
have crucifixion this country be a right
bloody mess I want you to move me to
another
[Applause]
cell oh look at that Bloody
favoritism they hung me up here 5 years
ago every night they take me down for 20
minutes then they hang me up again which
I regard as very fair and if nothing
else he's taught me to respect the Roman
the Roman apologist
prisoner pilot wants to see you I think
he wants to know which we you want to be
crucified NIU like it these are lower
middle class people that love
billionaires right here this you guys
exist this
is you guys you're out there this is
what you like like to people this is
this you these are them these are Elon
mus sympathizers this is
you c h only one Survivor
throw him to the floor what's throw him
to the
floor the little rascal has Spirit has
What Spirit yes he did Sir
spirito a touch of living do oh uh about
11 sir oh you dare to wait us to what
sir strike him Centurion very
roughly oh my God that slap is right
favorite
part Jewish rep scallion I'm not Jewish
I'm a Roman a Roman no no
Roman it is good like
this he was a centuri in the Jerusalem
Garrison what was his name naus
Maximus do you have anyone of that name
in the garon well no sir you sound very
sure have you checked well no sir um I
think it's a joke sir like silus or
biggest di
sir biggest funny about biggest
di what is a joke names her I have a
very great friend in W called Big
[Laughter]
di you will find yourself in Gladiator
School very quickly with rotten Behavior
like that can I go now sir
wa your biggest of
this wait take him away this this is a
good set I will not have my friends
ridiculed by the common soldiery anybody
else feel like a
little
gigle when I mention my friend
[Music]
big what about you do you find it
visible will I say the
name
[Music]
because he has a wife you
know they're all having so much fun you
know what she's called biggest titis
she's
called incontinentia dang
it close close incontinentia but
[Laughter]
Fe
him your noes and
[Music]
[Applause]
him what what what is suddenly happening
what just
happened oh my goodness no oh I was
unprepared was nothing could have
prepared me if you told
me those creatures do look awesome
though what is happening I don't
know we've left Earth with
Brian and these
creatures there's a space fight in this
Roman Empire
[Music]
movie is he going back I don't know was
this just what is going on weird space
five minutes and now he gets dropped
back that's exactly what I hoped it
happen those three minutes were not
necessary whatsoever that's
great lucky
bastard that's how we got away at this
back how much quick what it's for the
wife 20 shekel right there you are wait
a minute well we we supposed to
no no I've got to get what you mean no
no no no no I just paid
you this bloke wle
wle I want 20 for that I just give you
now you telling me that's not worth 20
shekels all right I'll give you 19 then
this isn't worth 19 you just said it was
worth 20 oh dear oh
dear all right I'll give you 10 that's
more AR it 10 are you trying to insult
me me with a poor dying
grandmother
offer me 14 I'll give you 14 he's
offering me 14 for this 15 17 my last
word I won't take a penny less or strike
me dead 16
done I'll throw you in this as well I
don't want it but
thanks that's right that's four for the
god four for this G four look at it it's
worth 10 if it's worth a
shkele their glorious deaths should
unite us all in a look
out
someone put their end the bag yet that's
my favorite one love the guy standing up
and putting over him we have reason to
believe you may be hid in one Bri of
Nazareth no I'm just a poor old man I
have no time for law Breakers my eyes
are old and B quet silly
[Music]
person sir couldn't find anything
sir that was
lucky you stupid bird brained
flattered there's one place we didn't
look I think they speed stuff up in the
foreground which is interesting
yeah like there yeah how do they them
but not them maybe he was a little bit
they're just not M they stand really
still so it's like so it's like that's
fun
open up you haven't given us time to
[Applause]
hide do an act Brian come on Brian you
could do it don't pass judgment on other
people or you might get judged
yourself that's a nice good what how
much do you want for the good I don't
you can have it everything yes consider
the lies don't you want a Heckle
no consider the lies well the birds then
what birds any
birds have the birds got jobs what's the
matter with him says the birds are
scaming the birds they do all right
don't they well good luck to them yeah
they're very
[Laughter]
pretty
now now hear this blessed are they for
they shall inhibit their
G only shall be
given to them shall be given
what
finished
secret is this Brian Gathering
disciples like he's becoming the the
prophet
is that his
G this is the holy
gourd it is his cour we will carry it
for you master
master he's gone he's been taken
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
enough
that's a cool POV yeah that's great he
given us a shoe the shoe is a sign let
us follow his example hold up one shoe
and let the other be upon our foot for
this is his
sign gather shoes together in abundance
cast off the shoes follow the
go the Holy G of
Jerusalem hold up the sandle true is
true I love this how you interpret
prophecy yeah these are all the
different religion yeah basically and
I'm sure if you broke it down there's
some commentary on like different
sects one message accidentally given
interpretation is there another path
down to the
[Music]
river oh my [__] oh I'm sorry sh you 18
years of to
silent oh I'm
alive his beard was falling off I love
how he also looked dead into the lens up
complete
shot speak speak to us Master speak to
us go
away
[Applause]
[Music]
there is no food in this high mountain
what about the Juniper bushes over
[Applause]
there I say those are like Juniper
bushes they are a gift from God all I
bloody got to
eat the M healed me I didn't touch him I
was blind and now I can
see
tell to stop it a word it's a lot oh my
God ha Messiah I'm not the Messiah I say
you are Lord and I should know I
followed a
few you break my bloody foot you break
my fow of silence and then you try and
clean up my
Jay off this is the Messiah the chosen
one now he's not an
unbeliever persecute kill
the crucify
him
[Applause]
please Ryan
J oh they only met like twice yeah
moment that's all it
takes oh they got to it quick you know
love it Second Sight he's the Messiah
yeah he knows how to love and stuff yeah
Brian yeah Brian good old Life of
[Music]
Brian I was not expecting
that that's great that's
great what have you been telling them
nothing I only you only make it worse
for yourself look I can explain oh no
let me explain Mrs Colin your
those people out there are following him
because they believe in him Mrs Cohen
they believe he can give them
H that that's Judith mom Judith
mother now you listen here he's not the
messah he's a very nauy
boy I'm his mother that's
to
[Music]
you don't need to follow me you don't
need to follow anybody you've got to
think for yourselves you're all
different we are all different I'm
not that's a point don't let anyone tell
you what to do otherwise I'll
know what you said just now was quite
extraordinary we don't need any leaders
you're so right registering Dom ating us
for too long you're very
attractive your Nick me all
[Music]
[Laughter]
Beauty do we have any crucifixions today
139 sir now we have 140 nice round
number
a his shoes were amazing take them away
our Roman I you prove in honesty and
crucify him well let me come with you
Pontius I may be of some assistance if
there is a
CR they drag him off they're going to
crucify him right this calls for
immediate
discussion that there be uh immediate
action uh once the vote has been taken
well obviously once the been take you
can't act on a resolution till
you it's happening re something's
actually happening re can't you
[Music]
understand Big Horns are back bring them
back
always we have Sam the sedes Strangler
[Music]
silus crucifixion yes good out of the
door line on the left one cross each
Jaya excuse me there's been some sort of
mistake just a moment Jayla how many
have come through
what uh how many have come
through what
uh speak of a
bit uh how many have come
through oh dear I make it 90
96 get a move on big noses people
waiting to be crucified out
here do do you have a lawyer no but I'm
a Roman how about a [__] we got plenty
of time oh boy miserable bloody Romans
no sense of
humor I'm sorry a bit of a hurry can you
go straight up line on the left one
cross each this movie could never be
made today Madness a lot of
Madness crucifixion Party by the left
forward you
lucky who is this Star Wars guy that I
am your father he's young and he looks
exactly like that guy and it's bugging
me I haven't thought of his name this
guy yeah you know the guy God what is
his freaking name Adam Driver yes oh I
definitely see the ad driver V God bless
you Coy Adam Driver yes I shall release
Brian you mean I'm have to give up being
crucified in the afternoons
CH I would have nothing to do oh thank
you they gone we we got lumps of it
around the back oh don't worry about him
sir he's he's he's he's he's M have they
gone
no oh come on yes sir my brain sounded
like when I was trying to think of Adam
driver's name you went through this you
lived it you experienced it that's the
motion to get on with it P with a one
exstension I now propose that we go
without further Ado man have
a oh I love it policy up you go be no or
warn you I'm going to punch you so hard
you Roman G shut
up under the terms of the Roman occupant
we're entitled to be crucified in a
purely Jewish area ends up all those who
don't want to be crucified here hands
up
next uh it's not my cross I was at
holding it for someone just lie down I
haven't got all day no of course
um no of course oh it's great point out
first Brian in all fairness that we are
not in fact the rescue committee however
I have been asked to read the following
prepared statement on behalf of the
movement are we the people's front of
judia brackets officials in Brackets
your death will stand as a landmark in
the continuing struggle to liberate the
parent Land from the hands of the Roman
imperialist aggressors excluding those
concerned with drainage medicine roads
housing
education signed on behalf of the pfj
ETC what are you going to do goodbye
Brian and
thanks a
good
H and so say all of us and so say all
of where is BR nazare I have an order
for his release yeah I'm BR and Nazareth
take him down I'm Brian of Nazareth I'm
Brian Spartacus moment I'm only joking
I'm not really
[Music]
Brian who are these
guys DN
[Music]
[Applause]
people's what
the People's Front cck
[Music]
Squad that show them
Ryan
Ryan to death terrific great re has
explained it all to me and I think it's
great what you're
doing I'll never forget
[Music]
you that's how you treat your poor old
mother in the Autumn years of her life
all I can say is go ahead be crucified
see if I care see if I care some things
in life are bad they can really make you
mad other things just make you swear and
curse when you're chewing on life's
gristle back Rumble give a whistle
always look on the bright side of
life always look on the light side of
life
if life seems jly rotten there's
something you
[Music]
forgotten never would have thought we'd
get here nope me neither now I thought
it would
[Music]
land
bre what you got to lose you know you
come from nothing you going back to
nothing what you lost
[Music]
nothing nothing will come from nothing
you know what I say Che up
[Music]
you
fascinating
oh
boy this was so long ago I did not
recognize anyone like I know all of
those names but I could not tell you who
played who and that feels odd but kind
of freaking it was not I feel like I
recognized John C because I feel like
he's been around more
recently other than that didn't really
didn't know didn't know except for that
one guy looks like Adam Driver except
Adam driver's pre probably 10-year-old
Cameo as a grown man thank you to
Shopify for sponsoring which is what we
use for our merch store and is our
gamechanging partner in e-commerce so
whether you're launching a passion
project or scaling to new heights
Shopify is the e-commerce Powerhouse
guiding you at every step from creating
your first online store to opening
physical locations Shopify makes it
seamless it's perfect whether you're
selling exclusive merch or unique
Collectibles thanks to their
all-encompassing platform for both
online and in store sales their checkout
system unmatched it's 36% more effective
at converting visitors into buyers than
other platforms and let's not forget
Shopify magic the AI tool that elevates
your business with minimal effort but
seriously reflecting on our journey
using Shopify for www.re naations
shop.com it's been transformative the
transition smooth growth exponential
thank you again reject Nation from
simplifying sales to scaling our
offerings Shopify has been a Cornerstone
of our success and Shopify isn't just
for us it Powers 10% of us e-commerce
backing businesses big and small in over
175 countries there are war-winning
support always there to guide you so
ready to join the revolution sign up for
Shopify at only a dollar a month at
shopify.com rejects all overc case
shopify.com rejects start your Shopify
success story now let's grow together
with Shopify team big thanks to
expressvpn for sponsoring this video a
real game changer I've been using for
years that's right years so whenever
they want to work with us it's an
instant yes you've likely heard about
expressvpn for online privacy and
security but there's more to it than
that however there was a very real
incident recently with Spectrum Shing
down my internet and contacting me due
to a suspecting hacking attempt and
funny enough I realized I hadn't
actually activated my expressvpn on my
new laptop that I got a couple of months
ago so I was paying the consequences
having faced a serious hacking issue on
YouTube a couple years ago that made
express vpm my go-to for both security
and freedom I mean it and yes what
you've heard is true believe me this
channel knows you can use expressvpn to
watch movies and shows on Netflix that
are not available in your country this
means accessing a vast rate of content
of over 100 countries like a global
Cinema your fingertips it's super easy
open expressvpn switch locations refresh
the browser and there you have it
whether it's kramas on South Korean
Netflix Hulu BBC I player YouTube or
more expressvpn has you covered and it's
incredibly fast ensuring no buffering or
lack for smooth HD streaming it's
versatile too working on not just
computers but phones media consoles
Smart TVs and and more this means you
can enjoy your favorite shows on
anywhere any screen protect and elevate
your internet experience so if you want
to get access to hundreds of new shows
use my link expressvpn.com Rejects and
you can get an extra 3 months of
expressvpn for free that's
expressvpn.com rejects so head to
expressvpn.com rejects to learn more
thank you again uh well now if you're
listening to this on Apple podcast or
Spotify please do like and or review let
us know how you're enjoying it we're
going to dive into a review of Monty
Python's The Life of Brian which we just
watched for the very first time and what
an experience it was yeah uh I didn't
know what to expect I didn't know
thematically tonally objectively
spiritually what to get into uh but it
was good it was weird uh it was
definitely not of my era and that was
also fun like I definitely think that
this informed a lot of things from
Comedy that I grew up with but it
predates it by a gener or two um you can
see the DNA of a lot of comedy in here
for where we developed what you think I
mean I love that they're in all of the C
they're in every single sketch like I
don't know why I didn't know that but
Monty Python like the whole cast plays
all the characters which I love yeah um
I thought it um it was great uh I like
the I think what I like the most is like
the pacing of the tone in in like the
era and the exact comedy that they're
doing they do the pace in the tone of it
really well in this like there's a
specific style that they follow and uh I
like that also the fact that like every
sketch is kind of like a metaphor
telling you something about uh like uh
Christianity or religion or like the
Jesus stuff uh also like I don't know it
just called to a lot of things but also
adding in uh humor to it which I really
really liked yeah I think the narrative
worked really well too to deliver
messages in an absurdest way like
there's so many metaphors and there's so
many moments of like you know he's not
he doesn't want to be a leader and he's
just trying to say to live your own life
and everybody taking that on and and we
we even commented a couple times about
like how scripture can be manipulated
and and how people themselves interpret
it differently and therefore Runner so
it was fun to have like you're saying
every every 3 to five minutes was a
different individual section that then
combined an act into a threea structure
it's really well written to have so many
different pieces add up to a hole but
each piece could be its own you know
peel sketch yes exactly I agree with
that like if it'd be like if Chappelle
Show was a feature like grabbing you
know a bunch of little vignettes of
Comedy but having this overarching story
it's really impressive writing and and I
liked that I didn't have I honestly
can't tell you who 90% of the cast was
and I know those actors and and it's so
long ago I really enjoyed the escape to
just go like I don't have any
association with these folk I can just
enjoy the absurdity and I think one of
my favorite moments was the the peak
absurdism of the the alien cuz like that
was yeah that was just a punchline like
it was just so he could escape to come
back and just why and I love that I feel
like because he was in like a yellow
submarine looking like spaceship yeah
definitely had some Beatles Vibe right
and but also isn't there a thing correct
me if I'm wrong and I probably am but in
like latterday Saint stuff or
Mormonism like he goes in no joke a
yellow submarine or a spaceship and he
that's how Joseph get it's like Salt
Lake City and that's why when you die
you get uh you get a planet with your
wives I swear to God you guys I am not
obviously I'm not making this up because
it's so absurd but I was like oh are
they calling out that one weird part
where they're like he took a yellow boat
submarine over over here and it's in
their book of whatever they call it my
favorite thing about religion is it all
sounds just as crazy as the last thing
to me I know uh I no disrespect to any
religious folk but I I know less about
religion than I know about my five eight
grandparents ago I just don't I don't
know I don't know this world and I'm
sure there's a lot of really funny humor
if you have layers to it if you have
yeah like if we knew more about any of
it we would be like oh behind the scenes
uh real rejects when we got here Greg
this aside and went do you know about
Jesus and it was the funniest Sunday
school moment where I was like not
really like I've seen Mel Gibson's movie
and I just went the Father the Son and
the Holy Ghost yeah I think there's like
a trinity thing which wasn't in here no
not at all I also like there was no he
wasn't the Son of God we didn't really
go to Jesus we didn't go to him like at
all Brian just got born next door Brian
was just in the same in the arena yeah
the same like delivery room we had we
had Brian which was fun because I'm sure
there are parallels I'm sure this is the
story of Jesus taken obviously to to
absurd levels but uh I imagine it's a
retelling in points but not knowing I
don't know like meaning them asking his
mom if she was a
virgin
how got which I enjoyed how that became
The Narrative of like oh she reacted
like she must be like that was funny but
otherwise like there's probably a lot of
stuff the reason we didn't comment on it
is we don't know we don't really we
don't really know I was trying to really
think I was like oh man is he going to
go into a rock tomb and we come out days
later is there a sequel to life Bri
about Easter also is that what Mel's
doing a passion to is it gonna be the
Easter story like he comes back because
that's what I assume he has to do and
then we get a Trilogy yeah which is has
come back in modern day as Mel Gibson we
need to get into a church before that
yeah it's got to happen but I I expected
a little bit more of the limited amount
know uh but also I don't know what like
the Easter Bunny like eggs have to do
with Jesus or any of that stuff like all
of that's just as absurd as any of this
to me so I don't know you know what I
mean like you just described his
spaceship and I was like seems like it
could be a thing maybe I swear to God
you guys like Joseph who wrote it I
remember they're like Dad he does this
no it's not his it's like a j it's like
a Joseph prophet and he the Yellow
Submarine and is that where the Beatles
got the Yellow Submarine maybe was from
like a bibl thing I swear we're going to
I'm going to have to look it up I mean
I'm tired right now but once I get in
the next month I'll figure this out you
guys or you guys will yeah you can I'm
sure let us know in the comments below
uh there was no like Adam and Eve ribs I
thought maybe there'd be like some baby
back ribs jokes uh the my point is all
of the jokes I expected to occur for my
limited exposure did not um so I
expected like you know some baby back
ribs jokes some uh some Easter eggs
jokes some stuff that like from my
limited knowledge so this was really
interesting and fun for me because I
didn't get most of it but I could still
appreciate the humor um I would liken it
to how I imagine people that have never
read a comic would enjoy a comic movie
where it's like I can enjoy the surface
level of the entertainment but I'm sure
there's so much going on for people like
me in the comic sense to be like oh my
God that's a blah blah blah like this is
probably full of uh Jesus Easter eggs
Jesus if you will uh where it's like
there are elements that we just don't
actually Easter eggs probably be a Jesus
thing too cuz the Easter eggs totally
the only thing we got was biggest Dickus
biggest dickas is probably my favorite
of the holy men I know for me it was
okay my favorite part of the movie
though real quick was his his slap the
slap was so good I the slap is my most
favorite thing I'm like if anyone was
like you need to rewatch that I'd be
like I feel like I'm good but I would
yeah I I enjoyed a lot of sections yeah
I found myself really being invested and
then kind of in and kind going back and
forth I agree which is I think how they
keep probably most people invested
because there are some short stints you
know they're going to cut out of this
eventually so if they're losing you it
keeps moving and it's going to move into
a different a totally different sketch
yeah which is great because you're like
oh thank God we'll be we'll be through
this in a sec yeah yeah which is good
and that's probably smart to have
something in this narrative um with
styles of humor like I I particularly
enjoyed the I mean the biggest dick is
I'm I'm a child so I really enjoyed a
bunch of Romans trying not to giggle
that worked for me uh silly lisps and
things uh at one point you said this
could never get made it it definitely um
from just the theme just the concept no
one would let people play in this Arena
today uh we're we're a bit and also I
think there's a freedom to the British
um I think you know Borat um you know
that is you know what I mean like that's
the modern take to me I I see Sasha bar
Cohen is the modern Monty Python I agree
and in the middle was Mel Brooks to me
uh Mel Brooks is one of my favorite like
comedian director writers uh men and
tights I love so much it actually ruined
the Godfather because I watched Men and
tights like through my whole childhood
and then I watched Godfather in my like
early 30s yeah so when I watched The
Godfather I was like I've seen all this
but like as a joke like all of the the
cheek stuffing stuff like all of those
scenes were rude because they were funny
to me in The Godfather so that smell
Brooks like he and I I have
thank you Mel Brooks but Brooks is so
funny that I couldn't like straight face
watch the most famous of mob movies oh
my God I can't so that's what I felt
like this was definitely setting up oh
yeah yeah yeah for sure um I I'm trying
to think of like what were the my other
like favorite moments also why is Judith
so fit she had like there's one cut to
her and she has like 18 ABS I was like
girl get it Judith was doing the work
yeah and I like that the mom was like
leave her alone for a minute and he's
like but I don't want to yes that was a
great line I enjoyed that and it was so
thrown away it wasn't even like very
loud but I really really like that um I
like the throwaway lines like with Mary
Walking Away of like oh children they
don't and when she's leaving him at the
crucifiction like what gotten into the
kids these days I like the the throwaway
lines that they do with certain
characters in this those make me laugh
like the end of a scene of someone just
saying stuff um also the mob when
they're following him um and repeat just
like repeating things but when they like
oh yeah we're going to just blah blah
blah I don't know I really like that
type of uh uh delivery I guess you could
say I like seeing 200 extras we don't we
don't get movies like this anymore so
many and why were they always they were
always like smiling and panting they
were like oh it was so hot so happy so
so Labrador Retriever energy for all
those followers actually I think that
one of those sequences is probably up
there for me as well as the uh the
biggest dickas was just the the
throwaway nature nature of the joke
about how people can interpret religion
cuz that that carried on for a while
like the the tree you know the all those
things where it's just there but it
becomes a miracle and how I think people
need uh certain types of people need to
believe so how especially when you're
being persecuted You' need someone or
something to give you hope and belief
and faith and all that jazz so obviously
it wasn't handled seriously here but the
idea that these people feel persecuted
these people are are being taken
advantage of or you know not feeling
like they're represented going like this
man can lead us like please someone lead
us and you know handled through humor
and and like as an outlet but there's a
lot of a truth in people wanting that
that freedom to follow yeah there is I
mean I think people are constantly
looking for a leader but it also
distracts them from like their own brain
and what they're struggling with because
I mean when he's at the window he's like
you're all different you're all
individuals you got to go and figure it
out for yourself you can do it don't
listen to anybody except for most of the
world is like I would like to listen
to follow who can we follow around here
and maybe it's like a society where
they're like stand in line in
kindergarten and follow him and follow
that I mean not really but you guys get
what I'm saying no I mean that's even
the scene with the cruv like with the
CR they just do it yeah which is that's
right especially when they're all in the
good that was my other favorite part
good I love that good good did take a
left that my that was one of my
favorites another favorite of me uh
would be the scene where they're
breaking down all the Romans have done
oh yeah where it's describing the Roman
Empire and like the Roman Empire changed
human beings we do have you know law and
and Agriculture and sanitation like all
that came from this era and obviously
that's over hundreds and hundreds of
years but to to make it so succinct that
joke was so funny to me of like what
because every time they're always like
the oppressor what have they ever done
for us and it's still true that you're
trying to escape you know the
colonization oppressors but the list of
all of the accomplishments that happen
under this regime it's very interesting
to look at the Nuance of when you've got
a dictatorship or an actual colonization
or someone making law where it's safe to
walk in the streets but at what cost
that's that's a funny Nuance to look
into of of we're living in in in our
society in 2023 we're living in this
very orwellian Society of you know we
feel safe because we have ring lights on
our doors and like the cameras I don't
because I don't want to be watched all
the time but some people feel safe by
putting themselves in the position to be
watched all the time and that's
literally what we wrote about in the 80s
as surveillance state so we we have Siri
on her phone and we have all these
things where it's like we literally are
being listened to and watched and all
the things that the80s warned us about
but it's safer so we do it and in here
we've got you know this list of things
the Romans have made society better
about but they're still oppressing
they're still not letting them be
themselves so it's an interesting
commentary on on what you're willing to
accept as a a hierarchy yeah I agree and
it's also like educational too like if
someone just didn't know about the Roman
Empire what a way to learn wow like just
watch this sketch real quick kid all
right let's uh go ahead and play that uh
that's actually be good to play in
schools right like if you're doing a a
class in the r Empire and then have this
be the like final like after you're done
like this yeah here's the funny thing
and now we all remember like what they
did but also what they also didn't do
well yeah like a nice summation of the
accomplishments and the horrors yes yes
cuz yeah I I enjoyed that balance I
thought that was funny that was one of
my favorite scenes was that just that
run through and thinking about the
Nuance of of humor in that way like yeah
and I was like is it called the school
of rock cuz I was like this I think you
were right when you said School of Rock
because that animation with the titling
in my brain it was like that and then
that sketch also reminded me that along
with when he was doing the Romans go
home I was like this is School of rockes
out loud like yeah and yeah that scene
was great too the Latin
repeating and all those I was like dang
I don't remember a lot of English yeah
and I don't remember how to conjugate
Latin God no that was impressive I mean
Americans barely learn the one language
we have to everyone else learns like
four all right it's we we are
unfortunate we're not uneducated people
we're not we're sorry Romans didn't get
this far we are we do what we can uh as
per a lot of people that are probably
upset that we I mean this is a movie
jabbing at religion so I'm hoping I
didn't fit anyone with my my uh
aggressive atheism but uh this was enjoy
mon python is defitely something I have
very little exposure to more abstractly
Terry Gill through like you know fer
King Dr Parnassus Brothers Grim uh you
know he's got a legacy and then John C
from being John C uh I would be curious
about you know what what's the other
classic one there's um meaning of life
there's Holy Grail the Holy Grail I
think those The Big Three yes yes and we
we haven't seen it we haven't seen them
so if you want us to watch watch any of
those this is probably the way I'd watch
can cuz in life it's hard to make time
for every movie but hisor would not I
would not I I don't know that I would
sign up to be like Monty Python and
let's do it with everything that is out
there that's I'm going to own that and
you guys know me that I'm always
complaining about in certain movies if
it doesn't have heart in it and makes me
like feel a thing that I'm like I don't
know it's pretty good but I wanted it to
have more of a a heart to it obviously
this is not really going to go there
this is sketch and very hard comedy
which is why is not a thing that I tend
to cling to that's proba the two that
haven't seen like yeah because we don't
we're not drawn to satire to the scale
no no uh but if you want us to watch the
other ones uh this is probably the way
we will ever watch them no disrespect to
Monty or python uh it's just uh not not
generally coming on the TV uh I'm more
of a darker humor kind of like you know
Kiss Kiss Bang Bang Lethal Weapon and
Bru kind of fella those are those are my
jams so I would love to watch these if
you guys would love to have us watch
these we haven't seen them so please do
sign up below letting us know which ones
you want us to watch and this I will say
as we sign off uh I did appreciate that
it had that liveliness of Live Comedy it
felt like at points like a play like
people laughing people breaking people
like that SNL element bre yeah and that
that made it more enjoyable because to
see them doing that made it like a more
fun time for me get it alive yeah so I
would love to see the others if if only
for the spontaneity of like people
breaking that that joy that jubilance of
live theater that is uh that did
translate really well here yeah all
right that is going to do it you
lovelies thank you so much for joining
us on this like comment and ring the
bell ring the bell can't top it much
love reject Nation we'll see you soon
[Music]
bye